[Music]
how is cristian cásseres greeting you with
his news briefing from news now in
spanish there are new guidelines on the
use of masks the centers
for disease control and prevention or
the cdc announced on thursday that
vaccinated people no longer have to wear them
masks indoors and
some closed places there are some
exceptions such as events with crowds
of agents public transport
hospitals among others despite the
new guideline the government is letting
the states cities and businesses
determine their own guidelines and
well here in nevada some businesses
Well youngor hotels are already revealing their guidelines as well as
investor properties announced
that they will not force their
vaccinated guests to wear masks
inside their establishments
new charges were filed against the accused of
killing the 2-year-old marine cos in
police say mother's boyfriend
is responsible for her  death his name
about the fraud he now faces four
more charges after confronting an officer
during his arrest according to documents
obtained bronx told
authorities he
was angry because he loved and had
gotten on himself so he hit the boy
several times for that reason the  The body
of the minor was found only on
Wednesday roads will have its next
hearing on Monday and I heard this
huenchual is preparing to open its
doors the park is located in the
southwest of the valley and is preparing to
welcome families on
May 27 however to  for this to be
possible they also need employees the
water park is holding a
job fair from today until sunday
from 12 to 4:30 pm and
the heat continues to rise here in our region
we will approach 100 degrees by the
day of  today however we will have some
40 mph winds for the
weekend i am cristian cáceres with
super informative from ilumin  ado en
español good day
[Music]